shooby dooby dooby gang let's go the
state trashy tour is in full swing we're
coming to a town near you we got the
first leg announced yes we're coming
other places first leg coming up grab
the squad come to the show yeah guys
starting in March we're gonna be in
Baltimore Virginia Beach Richmond
Virginia Oklahoma City Dallas Texas
Houston Texas Austin Texas then in April
New Haven Connecticut Burlington Vermont
in May we're hitting Tampa Dania Beach
Florida there you go Raleigh North
Carolina then in June we're hitting
Cleveland and Columbus we're going to be
announcing a bunch more cities but
tickets are already moving now get them
let's party yeah welcome to another
exciting edition of are you garbage the
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah it's a little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find that the girl to
be classy yeah after just a big old
piece of trash I'm your host Dave
trolley coming at you on a beautiful day
we're down here at antodi's basement
she's upstairs flying the colors okay
they got a pseudo Brit in the Crowd Oh
yeah she's something sticks the red
coats are coming
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he is the CEO of are you
garbage he is an international
businessman and I tell you what my best
pal in the whole wide world give it up
for KJ Kevin James Ryan hey what's up
gang thank you for tuning in as always
please make sure your rate if you
subscribe on iTunes oh yeah full video
available on YouTube as you know those
numbers are roof cooking then obviously
the greatest gosh darn website of all
time
www.patreon.com are you garbage check it
out you get a bunch of bonus episodes
ayg hard feelings a whole nother show we
got all kinds of good stuff over there
check it out gang yeah we do love that
money how about a nice quick shout out
to our producer extraordinaire the magic
man makes us all look good works the
ones works the twos crosses the t's and
dots the eyes give it up for T-Bone
mcgruffins it's Toby McMullen everybody
come on hey T-Bone what up dudes what's
up pal oh this is great This Guy's in a
Yeti cooler hat he looks like he knows
his way around a pontoon boat
[__] came to play Good Vibes when the
kid rolled in fact right away I like it
gang the long hair ain't lying
we couldn't be more excited to have our
incredibly and I mean incredibly special
guest here with us today for the fourth
time he has a very funny stand-up
comedian writer actor and podcaster and
you may have seen him in but not limited
to we got a very Harold and Kumar
Christmas we got money from strangers oh
yeah we got Sullivan and Sons we got
Marin we got the Goldbergs we got new
girl we got Hoops which he also wrote
two episodes we got arrested development
also wrote two episodes of that we got
Gotham Comedy live he is the co-author
of the amazing book The United States of
absurdity he's on tour right now and of
course he is the co-host of the dollop
and here's the turkey has a brand new
special out right now with all things
comedy entitled England weed and the
rest but the big question with his mind
today is he garbage he came in here with
a rucksack like he was on his way to a
hospital I think he summited at the
moment give it up for Gareth Reynolds
everybody let's go yeah all right kids
here I knew I walked in where I was like
they're being very gracious but you're
just waiting
just we're patiently jotting notes he
had a pickaxe I don't want to say the
biggest goddamn backpack I ever saw in
my life full of hands if that helps it's
just human hands it's nothing weird hey
where can I put my ears yeah
you guys want to buy hands
oh man thanks for coming Bobby thank you
thanks for having me truly great yeah
give us the scoop now I know there's
some British Heritage in you yeah which
got some royalty I'd like some I'm gonna
hold it against it although I'm dumping
out the tea in a bathtub when I get home
no not again [__] uh oh no sure I'm not
gonna swear YouTube yeah now you can
swear oh okay all right that was okay
it's like the feds they gotta stop
lifting after the first 30 seconds yeah
I know we don't if we don't curse in the
first 30 seconds we're gonna dump the
call
uh give us the scoop all right so yeah
English parents moved to America born in
Britain I was born in Wisconsin so I was
raised in Wisconsin by English people
and it was pretty weird now if the war
broke out you'd have to kill them first
you know that right I'm ready to kill my
dad I've been waiting for the good
morning since I was young I tried to
start the War I want it going now let's
go you're spreading propaganda yeah yeah
they're listening
um and then uh yeah it was really weird
and I like had a little British accent
growing up and then slowly in Brown Deer
Wisconsin I became a more wisconsiny
child my mother felt because that's like
America America like that's like Middle
America that's gone [__] I had a mullet
and Z's shaved in the side of my head
yeah you did so I went hard I respect
that yeah and uh she was like that's
like a sitcom two two parents from
[__] England moved to Wisconsin yeah
yeah and raised a little a little a
little chap yeah and they were losing me
because I'd be coming home and be like
what time is the Packers on it
any brothers or sisters an older brother
okay and then was he born in Britain he
was he was full-on
he was full on British and when my
parents moved to Wisconsin you know they
wear the little uh Schoolboy uniforms
sure so my mother's they moved to Ohio
first and my mother sent him to a
Cleveland
in his school uniform and he yeah he was
like I can't go back to school what what
did they do he's like I don't need
clothes I need new clothes he got me
dressed like a beetle what do you think
yeah and make it through homeroom yeah
and so he had he kind of like you know
he kind of like uh greased the wheels a
little bit for me made it a little
easier sure they were they knew that
like you had americanize you yes and I
was ready to go I was really ready to be
absorbed how much older than you is he
he's 12 years older totally [__] yeah
that took a break that's trashy right
there any double digits between siblings
yeah that's tough well and let me save
it like I think a lot of times people
think English people are classy there
are lots of pockets of big trash in
England well that's your parents trying
to assimilate to America they come over
here distinguished Brits they get they
get to America your dad knocks up your
mom 12 years later yep yeah yeah they
took a nice breather and uh what did
they do so my dad moved to Wisconsin or
to Ohio because he got a job uh working
for Brio toys which were like wooden
trains like Scandinavian wooden trees
and then my mother sold toys too so I
grew up with like two toy parents all
right
um human parents
yeah two marionettes yeah and so uh and
that was what they did and so I was like
you know like raise pipe this weird
little situation it was super the older
I get the more I go that was really
weird how did they do how was the
business doing when your dad was working
my dad did well this is what the 90s
were talking uh he well they moved here
uh I guess in the 80s okay or no they
would have moved here in the 70s sorry
and then yeah he started to do well like
Brio became like legit for a while and
um you know like they were it was like
middle class but they like they they did
well my mother did well you know they
didn't have to work their asses off they
did well yeah fine little house basement
that flooded constantly there you go
yeah there you go you get a sump pump in
there yeah yeah Bingo what was the house
like single family home single family
garage
burned down once completely
house really yeah
it's like God damn it again
we blame the Yanks we really felt like I
think it was we're pretty sure it was
the Yanks uh and uh but basically go
back to Britain's sign burns on the
front lawn gave it away it was very
School Ties it was very aggressive sure
but uh they uh basically my mother hated
turning the heat on because she was
raised super poor and so she would light
fires in the fireplace not just like my
mom's the same way so she did that and
then one day she was going out on a walk
which she did every day and she like
cleaned the ash out and put it in the
garbage can and it turned out there were
still some Embers in it so while she was
gone the garbage can caught on fire
caught the car on fire the car blew up
and and then someone driving by was like
I think like sounds like the Irishman I
don't know what you're talking about
taxis in the water
Maybe that's have a lot of enemies so
we're thankful yeah
yeah no it was a real good Fellas it was
a week after we were throwing rocks at
the Catholic Church yeah and the Rolling
Stones played right after which we
thought was a red flag it's like Tycho
put a hit on your dad yeah yeah yeah
I just remember my dad fell to his knees
and screamed Mattel
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Hot Wheels
these goddamn metal cars are killing us
yeah
and all the wood trains I mean they just
went up oh yeah of course I mean that
was just tender that's a liability yeah
did you get first dibs on all those toys
when you were a kid I assume yes right
the best one was remember Koosh balls
yeah so I I got it they were behind
Koosh balls well my mother was a sales
rep for Koosh balls she my mother's like
a rep so she just had a bunch of stuff
but I remember she came home and she was
like they called this the Koosh bowl and
I was like oh this that was a big hit it
was huge wow and I was and I was like I
liked and she was like what do you love
about it I was like yeah you're doing r
b yeah yeah yeah I was like on Molly I
was like I'm digging this thing and um
and but that was the big one that was
the one that's sweet you know and
remember you could like get you could
wrap some of the circular rubber bands
around here I was discovering all the
little pockets of fun yeah that's your
dream that's your dream that would be my
dream job to be like a buyer or a rep
for uh for a toy company would be all
right it was pretty good yeah it was
damn yeah and then it was compensated by
the fact that they were had a horrible
marriage so I got the toys to distract
me from the fact that they were like in
the yard sure arguing all the time did
they stay together they didn't no they
didn't stay together no they didn't make
it at what age did they uh split ways
I'm also a product of a broken home yeah
well when did yours part young I think I
was like three okay and then my dad then
again when I was like 20. there's a lot
yeah it's a splintered family that's I
kind of had like they sat me down at
seven and they were like we're
separating and I was like what in it so
I had to I had to yeah and uh they were
like they were like say what now this is
the longest I've talked to a British guy
without doing that and the fans would be
upset if I didn't do it it was real good
it was worth it Congratulations by the
way good on your mate
[Laughter]
yeah yeah taxation without separation
she's pulling away in a carriage yeah oh
she's floating she's not a witch I was
like Dad uh um okay but yeah so if they
were like seven we're separating is this
before or after the house fire this is
before the house fire is like seven
years later okay the house fire was when
they eventually got so they took seven
years so your brother's 19 at this time
yeah is he in the house is he out or is
it just you uh he's in college no yeah
he's going to UWM but he's also like
he's still in the house pretty much but
he's back and forth I mean I was like
seven and I was like we're best friends
and he was like you know he's like
smoking weed and getting DUIs shout out
to it yeah yeah congrats Kids America
and that turned out to be genetic uh and
so he uh so he so they basically like
we're gonna accept operated and I didn't
know what the hell that meant and then
they spent like seven years being very
confusing as far as what was going on
like were they both living in the house
well some sort of like my dad was
part-time there he would sometimes be in
the the bedroom with my mother this is
where you're gonna be like this is trash
uh uh so is what we like this is so he
so as a kid I was like what the [__] is
God but I never asked you know I was
like are they together but so yeah you
[__] her or what what's it yeah I'd
be like I think he is but I would be
like I don't want to know this so uh so
man she's married yeah do you
quit my dad's gonna kick his ass and uh
and so he so my dad would be there like
part-time sometimes in the same bed
sometimes on the couch bed sure and then
he also had an apartment like in
downtown Milwaukee a duplex where he
lived above a set of uh like volleyball
playing twins uh Ellen and Eileen who
shout out to them too yeah I've been
trying to find him yeah it's not easy
but
um so and then I went there like once or
twice to like spend the night and it was
truly like what I would imagine like if
your dad was a cop on Stakeout and it
was going badly felt like like I'd open
his fridge it's just like a lamp
swinging yeah yeah I mean yeah yeah and
so and then when I was 14 then uh my
father had kind of started another
relationship they go back and forth as
to how the timeline of all that sure my
father basically had another
relationship and uh and that woman was
pregnant shortly thereafter and then
that was when it was but you know I
think we were all like let's call it
yeah think it's time to good game guys
yeah yeah good on you yeah so you got a
new season yeah so you have a younger
half sibling of three yeah three yeah
very my facts three more kids yeah how
old was he when he was having those kids
he was it was not a good idea he was
because at that point he's got a 20 year
oldish I mean I think even older
honestly but uh yeah yeah I'm right
around there you were 14. I was 14 yep
and then and then so that family like
you know kind of flourished for a while
and I my dad and I basically stopped
talking for like really four or five
years sure yeah because I was like I
hate him what the [__] yeah yeah and um
getting all your wooden trains yeah no
the trains were gone that was the worst
part I was just like no
um you stayed with your mom at that time
with my mom yeah you felt I mean I felt
very like
you know like my mother was devastated
time so that's when I burned the house
down because I was like let's uh let's
liven it up yeah what are we doing let's
get another tragedy on the back burner
what do you say a little bit of
insurance yeah perfect way for you to
get about your about dad leaving let's
torch it now what aren't you thinking
about mom
um yeah so that was that was kind of the
cliff are you tight with them at all now
yeah super tight with my mother and very
tight with my father and what about his
the new family the kids siblings yeah I
mean I didn't talk to them for a long
time because I was like still I think
yeah
and uh and then but yeah over the years
yeah we we got closer I mean I'm still
much closer with my my brother but uh
but that you know I'm definitely yeah I
mean that's got to be a tough feeling
especially if you're 14 and you're going
to your dad's new family yeah you're
like an outsider tell well the thing
also was that like my family was so like
I you know you'd go to school and you'd
be like oh they got the perfect I would
go to other kids houses and I would see
the pictures like the you know an actual
photographer pictures and I and I wanted
that and I wanted a big trampoline and
then when I went to my new dad's house
with his family they had the pictures
yeah with his new family and so I was
just like I mean I was like older at
that point but I was still like smashed
a couple of those on the way upstairs
yeah
yeah I burn it I don't know what's going
on yeah I don't know every house I've
ever been in keeps catching fire this is
crazy let's go live with Ellen and
Eileen again those are the good days huh
all right wow that's a murky upbringing
yeah I respect it yeah so let's go back
to Mom's house because that's basically
where you were your your entire
upbringing yeah you were at the house
yep
um where was she shopping
was the grocery store uh Kohl's Kohl's
Kohl's grocery yeah department store
Cole's grocery so in Wisconsin herb
Kohl's does everything close is
everything we lived in a Kohl's I should
point that out I burned it though it
went right up to grabbing ham and the
regular pants yeah yeah that Kohl's cash
baby
yeah let's get some chips and sweaters
man
um okay and so there's Kohl's is a
grocery store is that still around I
think Kohl's is still around but it was
like thriving back then all right and I
think Kohl's department store is not
doing great from what I've I don't know
man my mom loves it yeah my mom loves
cold is it still going oh yeah
I don't sell lunch meat or anything like
that it's not a call you're going to
Burlington yeah you got to get the
Boar's Head I can't get a read on that
Kohl's yeah could have been good back
and does your mom still live in that
house no so sold it and then she moved
back to England and she lives in England
okay yeah what was uh what was the name
of that street growing up Cedarburg Road
that's pretty good anything with wood is
typically pretty nice Cedars a nice cut
of wood it was a good cut of wood how
was this guy gets back then you just get
it yeah it's a good train wood by the
way so I hear they move this guy knows
they move move oh yeah oh yeah
um what was the uh what was the grub
situation situation like growing up how
was your mom in the kitchen she was good
really yeah but I was like I again I was
real with Sky I liked garbage I really
not not to be on brand but I like I
would like a rack of ribs like from you
know like the cooked gross the the like
cooked in the grocery store
they did everything yeah all right now
that sounds scratchy got some sneakers
some ribs went home to use and um but
she was a great cook like all when I got
older I was like oh she's a great cook
was it was a traditional British food
like beef wellington and [__] like that
or could she throw down on like it was a
lot of spotted dick it was uh it was a
lot of [__] you're the only kid in
elementary school eating guinea fowl for
lunch part of me when we have Quail yeah
I uh no it wasn't I mean she would do
like Shepherds the kitty and Fox at the
end of the table he's got the hunter
outfit on
I play a horn before I eat
you enter the cafeteria
it's all right yeah so so I mean
it was definitely like British food sure
but it wasn't all Wellington but it
would be like but
yeah I mean there's a lot of Wellington
I'm not gonna lie I mean Cole's always
had it
um but it was you know like I didn't you
know you grow up in a house where it's
like weird you didn't realize it was
weird till later because I would always
have eggs and soldiers which is like a
soft-boiled egg and the neighbor and the
name
off and then the toast would be like
little lines that's [__] classy it
was I had an egg cup I mean it was
that's pretty good that was pretty good
she tried what is that how is that egg
cooked in there is it a soft-boiled egg
so it's like a hard boil a hard-boiled
egg but the middle the yellow cold out
so the yolks just take the top off but
you got as a kid you gotta eat around
that then you get a lot of uh yeah
I don't even remember how you did it I
think I just I think it was just for the
yolk really yeah very wasteful classic
British it's pretty good yeah Camp it's
all about that DraftKings baby we go
Birds oh we're talking about an official
sports betting partner a Super Bowl 57.
get over to the DraftKings baby spray a
little cash around yeah it's the middle
of the month you'll be all right here's
the turkey what's that turkey is drop
five bucks uh-huh they give you 200 to
play with and free bets instantly baby
yes I'm talking good money this ain't
one of hoodies and [__] Hooligans
that she runs around with these people
pay when time is right talking about
Super Bowl 57. you have to ask who our
picks are you're a goddamn Bozo because
we're betting a house on the birds I'm
going heavy on the Chiefs he took a line
of credit out I think she knows
something plus all customers can get in
on the Super Bowl 57 excitement with
DraftKings happy hour super boost check
the DraftKings Sportsbook app every day
between 6 and 9 pm Eastern to see what
prop bet will be boosted here we go
here's the turkey download the
DraftKings Sportsbook app now use code
ayg new customers can bet five dollars
on the Super Bowl 57 and get 200 and
free bets instantly spice up the game
you might not have a dog in a race but
you know what don't put it on the birds
baby throw a couple of bucks on the
birds it gets exciting only at
DraftKings Sportsbook with code ayg
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply void in Ohio C show notes for
detail kit what do you know about Adam
and Eve I know I'm hard right now
I got a stinger from here halfway to the
Mississippi what do you know about
getting weird in the living room
Valentine's Day coming up about to eat
my own ass
gang Valentine's Day is when you try new
things you're trying to save the
relationship God damn talk about a Hail
Mary let's go break out the double-sided
dildo in the chocolates and have a good
time
2023 have a little fun yeah even if
you're single do it to yourself our
listeners get 50 almost off almost any
item just use code garbage at checkout
and you'll get 50 off plus free shipping
that's 50 off an adventurous new toy yes
slippery Lube or almost anything else
you're talking about running around the
jungle either talking about getting
weird yeah going big or going home only
way to do it in the Boudoir I mean uh no
matter how big curtains gang unless
you're in this hell the neighbors are
doing construction no matter how big
your package ends up being it'll be sent
discreetly and for free generators sold
separately to have a happy Valentine's
Day go to adamandeve.com select any one
item and use code garbage this is an
exclusive offer so be sure to support
support the show and use code garbage to
get fifty percent off and one hundred
percent free shipping go to
adamandeve.com right now now back to the
show like the show are you a tea guy or
a coffee guy coffee you're a coffee guy
yeah Mom's a tea girl like yeah like 40
cups a day like a doctor needs to step
in I like that level I respect that
English okay
okay are you allowed to eat food in your
room
uh what were the rules of the house
there were they got I mean the good
thing about the parents being so
fragmented was that their rules came off
yeah the rules really kind of would she
work like when you would come home from
let's say like the like middle school
like you know sixth seventh grade would
your mom be home or would you have to
let yourself in and all that kind of
stuff I was pretty latchkey growing up
like I it it would vary because she
would be able to go out on like road
trips basically to go sell stuff but it
was real latchkey-ish for most of it and
then it got a little bit better when I
was like in Middle School she went out a
little bit less I think but but for the
most part yeah I was like left to my own
devices when were you allowed to stay
home by yourself like completely by
yourself like would she ever leave for
business trips and you'd just be at the
house no my brother would be yeah there
was the breaking point was this one time
when I was 11 my mother hired a 12 year
old to babysit me and that was when I
was able to be like like what are you
doing here yeah that was like my like
I'm gonna take this to the Supreme Court
was it a guy or a girl it was a girl all
right that's pretty cool though it was
but she definitely was like taking her
role too seriously sure and she and she
loved New Kids on the Block and I just
knew it was total [__] and then so
that was kind of when I started to be
able to be home alone a little bit more
because I was like this you don't like
come on yeah it's insane I'm gonna bang
this chick yeah
[Laughter]
uh okay what was a family vacation like
growing up
there were not a lot of those okay uh
Florida was probably the main
destination Disney or just like
somewhere else no it would be more like
I mean it would be more like my dad and
I would go on fishing trips more than
ever okay and then and then so like we'd
go to Florida a good amount was there
any family
here no no so England was really it to
go there we'd go to I'd probably go to
England once or twice a year I go to
England for basically every Christmas
yeah just probably do it all right yeah
pretty good over there yeah Rosy Cheeks
a lot of chimneys where was your mom
from near London no it's a small town
called stoubridge okay so it's like West
Midlands near Birmingham it's a little
like yeah it's where we're talking old
school yeah yeah it's it's you know
really like when you think of like a
little English town yeah it's one of
those yeah that's all right yeah he's
bad man pretty good I liked it I liked
it a lot huh yeah but they also in
England like they would do they would
start drinking earlier they would start
cigarettes or like you could buy
cigarettes at 16. you just didn't get
carted sure sure so I definitely would
like go to England start smoking weed or
start trying other [__] the bulbs or
whatever yeah and then come home and
then to my friends I'd be like it's time
that we are drinking yeah you can drink
rum now you know you're coming back like
a British Explorer I got I got laid the
first time at like 15. and I came back
and my friends didn't believe me sure
like well that's also that's also the
thing of like ah she's in England you
know what I mean like is English bro
with huge tits suck my dick oh yeah we
believe you guys she's my babysitter
it's a picture of Elizabeth Hurley yeah
I'm telling you man I'm doing her we're
married
I swear to God she gave this to me yeah
yeah okay that's pretty [__] mouth a
little bit Yeah quicker than a true
American guy yep all right what was the
high school mascot growing up Wildcat so
kind of that's like
yeah what was the name of the high
school uh University School it was
called University School yeah yeah okay
it was like it was a pretty preppy
school okay it's good school it was a
good school I was terrible at it okay
but it was a pretty good school I
respect that what uh what were the SATs
like growing up oh well you mean for
everyone or for me for you specifically
not good that's not good looking like I
mean real bad my neighbor killed it yeah
ah not great there's also the act in the
Midwest and that was the one where they
were like does he he has a brain or
what's going on yeah yeah like I think
you're like 22 on the ACT is like
terrible it's out of 30 30 high 30s I
think it's out of and I I'm I have never
I mean this is a conf I got a 17. I got
where where they where they were like
they were like what like someone drove
you home yeah they were like don't tell
anyone about this just don't you don't
want to go to some of these colleges put
this helmet on it don't talk to anybody
yeah yeah and SATs were all so bad but
what number on the SAT because he did
bad as well so you're in you're I
guarantee you're in good company I was
at a 1600 when I went yeah same I got a
870. I would guess I was around nine
midnight right that means
she could have been babysitting me
yeah not good though really really bad
any sports I was more of a theater kid
okay I played a little bit of soccer but
was just not good I played hockey two
for a long time okay they had a good
theater program there pretty good I mean
that was like the only thing I really
gravitated towards I was doing like uh
improv and at a place called Comedy
Sports which is kind of the only place
for for comedy this is in high school
yeah in high school
yeah and then uh and then plays like a
lot of like plays and [__] that was what
were you in hit me with a couple I was
in uh much to do about nothing nice I
was in Harvey okay yeah were you I was I
was the guy who talked to them yeah I
was in Harvey that's a Jimmy Stewart guy
yeah uh and um I was in Hello Dolly I
would do the musicals but wasn't good
um this is a High School Musical that
wasn't good I don't know if you can pick
your starting roles we're talking about
it was big who'd you play in what you do
I was dog Berry yeah all right it was a
pretty good little role not bad uh beer
boys yeah and uh and that that I really
did enjoy that was where I kind of like
because I was really not I mean I think
everybody was like this guy's not this
is not gonna end well and then I and
then I think I I really just kind of
like that kind of saved me like there
were a couple teachers who actually like
were really helpful because again I was
a like I said a 17. I was a really bad
student and so there were a couple
teachers who kind of stepped in and were
like so that you were dedicated towards
it was that thing yeah you got a
starring role in [__] Harvey man at
the [__] school they're showing up on
a Friday night that that turns a lot of
heads yeah it was good it was like it
was a thing and that really and then
that's like you know what kind of like
carried me off into like college and the
few you know but that was really like
that was kind of where I was like okay
there is something I can do and like
because up until then it was we were
really like how is this yeah trying to
figure it out yes what was the one good
what was the lunch situation in high
school would you buy would your mom pack
your lunch or would you pack your own
lunch it was like a hot lunch so you
wouldn't you wouldn't even buy it was
just like a prepped hot lunch every day
okay menu of like you know whatever
whatever they like it I did I mean I
really like I like but I realized like
there's two different kinds of people
people that like the school guy Victoria
and thought it was gross and I loved it
I loved it and I actually remember when
I was like told people I liked airplane
food and they were like I don't mind it
man
I really like
material food I was definitely I would
say a little more in the minority but I
was always like man these are pretty
good nugget yeah there's just something
about when they give you all the courses
at once when you have your little salad
eat the brownie first I don't care I
feel like a goddamn business yeah the
bar was low so I definitely yeah I would
eat whatever how is your palette now has
it expanded as you got older are you
still eating trash food I'm better now
yeah I I definitely am better if you're
going to the electric chair your final
meal what are you doing uh it could be
like pizza from I know wherever but like
what are you what is like the one thing
where you're like it's my [__] gotta
have my go-to I would probably do pizza
from a place called I mean I again I'm
like I live in LA so it's not I'm not
dominant you've got this little joint
Domino there's this guy that annoyed he
opened this place watch out for the
noise
unbelievable uh so it would be like uh
Numero Uno Pizza and fries and I'd
probably fold the fries and I get a
bottle of red
[Laughter]
that's good [__] what was the pet
situation growing up lots of pets really
yeah just anyone that showed up would
end up living there what was the
weirdest one you had any like anything
upstairs and what do you mean show up
like if a cat showed up on our porch my
mother would like feed it and then the
cat would know like within a few years
and come in the house yeah eventually be
in the house nice yeah uh any dogs yeah
multiple dogs many dogs probably a peak
I think we had five cats yeah it was
wild we were trying to fill some holes
yeah definitely some emotional things my
mother was like five cats is a dad
oh good oh it's a real date yeah that's
your father isn't that good any injuries
growing up as a kid break anything yeah
broke a wrist uh broke some fingers
uh got a lot of stitches got Staples in
my head and uh England once for what uh
I fell off a bike at universal
healthcare right there yeah that's where
you do it well that the people are
always like yeah Universal and they're
like we call it
yeah yeah exactly and I was like is that
okay it feels a bit archaic but uh yes
Staples and then you know yeah lots of
scars but nothing like too bad nothing
crazy nothing too crazy was your house
the sleepover house it became uh not
only the sleepover house when when my
dad was fully gone
um
so my mother
I was I was like smoking cigarettes on
the down low probably when I was like
14ish are in good company so then she
starts smoking really yeah and then at
some point she found out I smoked
this is like early High School holy she
found out I smoked and then we both kind
of just were like let's just smoke in
the house in the house so we were just
kind of smoking cigarettes in the house
probably around 14 15. now she wouldn't
she didn't want to tell anyone but then
that led to an easement of all rules of
course and then so by 15 16 I could have
parties at my house in my basement she
just kind of lost control of me and uh
and my friends are like there for it and
so we would just go to my once they
smell blood yeah and then and then you
know it was weed through the blow tube
and then it was like just weed yeah it
was all bold not a joint then it was
this yeah and then we they were pretty
slow there was uh there was a gentleman
who was not at full strength mentally
who used to bias alcohol and so we had
quite a little ecosystem going yeah so
we were getting whatever the [__] we
wanted and then we were able to do it
there but it all started with my I mean
I remember my mother and I just like
made making the decision to smoke
cigarettes in the living room you and
your mom are in the living room you're
watching TV you're 14 years old having a
heater yes
like like I throw in her the pack being
like there you go you know that's a soft
pack too but yeah oh yeah that was wild
yeah so that was totally nuts and that's
a recipe for a 920 on the SATs yeah no
[__] if it is a Mr 17 himself chapter
17. sharing a pack of Chesterfields yeah
fencing and hedges yeah yeah
so and then now we're getting there
folks with the mom at 14 yeah in the
crib yeah with five cats running around
five but I mean seriously it's nuts
imagine the smell in that house oh man
buying booze yeah yeah and Lance showing
up in the cuts yeah all right who would
cut the hair as a kid uh Super Cuts I
think would cut that all right I'll give
you that yeah definitely and again it
was for probably 10 or 11 years it was a
full strength mullet sure so that was
like you know it was the maintenance I
really really gravitated you're doing
Shakespeare with a mullet I think I'd
lost the mullet by then it's an
adaptation right there yeah yeah yeah we
got the babysitter we got College
covered what's what was the prom
situation equation you go
I definitely went to another School's
prom I think I went to my School's prom
yeah with a squad or with a lady uh I I
definitely I think I went with to my
prom with a foreign exchange student and
I think if I remember correctly I felt
kind of like guilted into it and I
didn't enjoy it oh and then I went to
the other schools prom because I was
kind of dating the girl and like went to
her prom but my problem I remember being
like man this is not enjoyable where is
she from I think she was from like
Argentina or something she it she was
from England that'd be weird you know
these types but she definitely was like
like I was like we should be drinking
you know and she was like God no and I
was like oh god well you're not gonna
like the nitrous situation later I'll
tell you that much we got a bunch of
balloons in the limo they're probably
gonna weird you out it's helium we're
doing helium I swear yeah our voices
just don't change our brains do it's too
bad Elaine's Discord us a couple of
Tanks
parties back at my mom's
by the way Lance got what he did from
tanking so hard really no no no I got a
buddy like that oh wow
yeah oh yeah all righty all right a lot
of that you rule dude yeah man yeah the
kids are all right now you're pretty
classy yikes classic Englishman I don't
know if I don't know what the audio
listener could feel my eye roll
also smoking cigarettes so at one point
all three of us smoking cigarettes so
they're just like the age it was it all
the wheels came off at some point yeah
the wheels were fully a headache yeah I
have a cigarette it's fine I will after
this yeah all right let's switch over to
now a little bit where are you living
now I live in uh L.A you're in L.A you
got your own place uh I have an
apartment yeah you have an apartment
yeah my own apartment one bedroom two
bedroom uh two bedroom two bedroom yeah
a couple of bucks a couple of bucks on
the kids doing it what's uh what's the
credit score looking like I think it's
pretty average I would say not great
okay normally when it comes for me to
use credit people I'm like what what do
you mean yeah yeah I thought I got
jammed up in college when you were young
I assume everybody else I I was just
cleaning mine up now it's more that I
just don't really have things
my credit is all fire right here
yeah those goddamn idiots uh I think
it's just that I never really had to
I've never really used credit I've
really yeah so I they always hit you
with that [__] dude it's not do your
credit's bad you just don't have a lot
of it yeah I'm [__] 22. yeah and I'm
like yeah yeah exactly yeah so yeah not
uh not great what kind of Steel are you
throwing around you got an Amex uh no I
have uh no I got a credit card with my I
have a credit union so it's a pretty
okay it's silver so drop too many
panties but uh any
um uh any miles programs like you have
like uh yeah what are you who you who
you linked with uh American Airlines
okay that's yeah gold pretty pretty good
okay yeah not to well yeah things things
are doing all right I'll be honest guys
I wasn't that confident about it but I
love the reaction are you hitting the uh
thank you are you hitting the lounges at
the airport I do a lounge yeah do a
lounge yeah yeah I mean but I don't I
don't fly as much as I used to but I'll
still do the lounge Lounge it up yep
okay you're playing first class or coach
or premium mainly mainly codes mainly
mainly coach take your shoes off yes big
shoe taker
yeah I've had I'm real into that I know
that there's a lot a lot of people first
of all you know I'm I've you know where
I'm from so it shouldn't surprise you
that much yeah yeah but my surprise you
have a shirt on no I know I do not I
left it in the lounge
look at these cats in here
you can't smoke up here sir I don't care
what your mom says
regulations go ahead flight attendant
it's cool my parents were divorced
that's fine uh I've had on a number of
occasions I've lost a shoe under the
seat in front
and I've had the person in front at some
point
do this and you're just like this is
pure shame animal that's crazy yeah and
that's I'm not kidding that's happened
15 times a month will you bring food
onto the plane yes yes I'll Pat yeah
give me an example well you bring it
through security will you buy it when
you're there I'll normally bring it
through security you're putting
sandwiches through TSA what the [__]
yeah guys nuts yeah Beef Wellington yeah
exactly serve it in the terminal yeah
I'll do both though I'll get a sandwich
at the airport or the food you're
bringing from home
uh-huh this isn't good I can tell by the
the palsy just it's honestly not good
this this might set me over the edge
I on a number of occasions have brought
uh eggs that I've cooked at home in
tupperware brought it on the planet oh
man like like scrambles I like fried
eggs wait you'll fry eggs why don't you
just eat them there Friday it takes 12
seconds to digest well because I'll be
like I want them later I'll be hungry
later and I'll try to like not eat like
like there's a rationale again at 17 on
the ACT
I'll I'll make I'll like cook them and
then I'll be like you know it's a
healthy healthyish meal so I'll just
make them at home to save a little money
just eggs uh some eggs and some toast
maybe something like that all right
doing a continental breakfast and Coach
that's crazy
don't bother yeah
somebody pulled out a tupperware on a
flight next to me I'd open that I'd open
the emergency door dude I'd have to I'd
have us landed no way no way would I sit
next to you dude I I definitely do this
too though I'll sit window and I'll
definitely like go I'll tell the story
if you have a bomb or something dude
hide it I'll hide it I'll hide it like a
Shameless yeah it's Shady the [__] are
you eating man I'd freak out yeah don't
worry it's fine he better be doing coke
over there buddy
Jesus dude yeah I knew that would go
over poorly
I knew that wasn't gonna go well dude
yeah nuts yeah it's not good carry on
only we check a bag I'll normally check
them how's he gonna get his grill on
there yeah I mean honestly what do you
think I gotta check the griddle yeah
yeah I gotta bring the lock
so I'll check the block eating stir fry
yeah yeah uh no it feels like a smuggle
I I bring a lot like I'll film all my
[__] on the road so I'll like pack a
bunch you might do a podcast on the road
of course all right huh when was the
last time you were on a boat and when
was it where and when that's a good one
um God damn I don't remember the last
time I was on a boat it's definitely a
pontoon boat yeah it was a pontoon boat
it's the best boat in the world is a pun
too it was a pontoon boat and it would
be in Big Bear California probably about
five or six years there you go Big Bear
all right oh yeah it's a hangovers and
yeah I love that what's your what's your
go-to sauce I'm sorry go please uh I
drink a lot of wine now because I used
to just drink so much hard liquor okay
throttled back a little bit yeah I used
to like beer and whiskey a lot my kind
of guy and then so I eventually had to
be like you can't like I got like I got
blackout drunk at a wedding probably two
years ago and I was like you are too old
to be like always a wedding to get you
when you get older really yeah well
because I reverted to like how I used to
be I was only two yeah it was it was
like it was like someone trying to just
like squat a thousand pounds that used
to be a power lifter and I was 50. yeah
so I just like every it was just a
nightmare and so then I've just gone
like just wine okay unless I'm like in
private in my own whose wedding was that
that was my buddy breath okay yeah are
you a spotted cow guy I love Spotted Cow
big spotted Spotted Cow it's like uh
Wisconsin's Yingling it's a religion
there yeah you can't buy outside of
Wisconsin Ah that's pretty good you got
wine at the house right now unopened
bottles I got two bottles of wine in
that hobo sack whoa uh yeah I got I have
lots of wine in my house big wine guy I
like wine you like the good stuff no all
right
truly whatever like whenever anyone's
like what do you want I'm like I was
really hoping he said he liked nice wine
again yeah all right there's no
Redemption no actually you know it
stresses me out when they pour the wine
for you at a restaurant to give of the
taster because I'm like this is so
unnecessary yeah I always you can't you
can you can just say just pour it yeah I
I normally like you know do anything
yeah I'll fake and be like that is
really good uh but that'll do it I'll
drink I will I'll drink yeah you're
saying something trashy yeah
it's got a nice rip
on the road on the road I'll go to a
7-Eleven and buy wine I really it's
7-Eleven I mean I'd rather go to a wine
store but if it's like still buy the
Jeep but if it's like CVS wine is what
you know I'll just go up there yeah what
combos pair well with this that sort of
stuff wow yeah a screw top man uh well
what let's be honest for sure it seems
like that technology has gone pretty
well and it's a little less labor
intensive sure so it screws up so I
definitely would gravitate towards a
screw top yeah drugstore wine holy [__]
do you have anything to pair with my 87
Jesus yeah
Sarah your shoes are off
yeah
thank you so much
how you doing in hotels
probably not great man is that great
will you ask to move your room if you
don't like the room if you've done that
he probably has to leave you I I they're
like the rooms complained about you sir
somehow the room called the front desk
I uh I I've rarely switched rooms if
like there's a TV issue one time I was
in I think like Minneapolis and I had
ants in my room and uh and I let it go
you guys party or what yeah I snorted
them I uh I let it go for like a day
and then I and then I and then I called
and I was like hey look there's ants and
then they sent someone up to raid the
room and the guy was like the guy's like
we're gonna raid it and I was like I I
think I gotta actually say I can't be
here any longer you can't you can't
[__] bug bomb myself and he and he
got it so early that I was like he knows
that's a horrible pitch like he was like
well rated all right you should go
somewhere else but yeah I'll never be
like ants in a hotel I'll never be like
this room isn't to my satisfaction okay
yeah you're leaving something for the
cleaning lady uh every time yep what are
you doing I'll do about five a night all
right good that seems to be the standard
we hear people saying yeah if you go for
the weekend 20 bucks or whatever yeah I
feel like solid I feel like the I don't
smoke weed anymore but I used to take
weed on the road with me all the time
and I that was my way of being like
we're okay with what I did in here
gotcha I like that but but they make the
maids do so much that I feel like yeah
sure definitely yeah yeah yeah I love it
so I was always under the impression
that they get paid per hour they're paid
per unit yeah right which I didn't know
until very recently take care of me in
the room for three or four nights I
don't have them come in to do no never
so yeah so it's like there's you know
there's a full track yeah I try to like
make areas that's a surprise party when
I leave yeah right they're like what
happened yeah how many men were in here
there's one it's all these ants look at
all the wooden trains okay uh we eat a
burrito in public
yeah okay yep like on a park bench you'd
throw down on a yeah if I had a nap if I
had sufficient napkins I would gladly do
okay uh are there any trophies on
display in your apartment now no no
trophy you have a fish tank no anything
that's a good question any plants yeah
plants doing all right yeah yeah the
other plants I take care of any pets now
yeah I got one cat okay driving not bad
good yeah he smokes what's your cat's
name Jose good cat name it's not bad
where'd you get them uh an ex-girlfriend
yeah you got a divorce no it was
actually she got the cat in the divorce
and then he was gonna get like
euthanized that day and so she was like
this cat's awesome and so she just
brought over the cat oh okay okay so I
was I went from no cat to a cat in like
an hour wow that's not bad yeah um have
you ever bought the floor model of an
appliance or a TV oh uh
I don't think so okay no good but if
offered I would be like okay if they'll
be hey we'll knock off 200 I'd be like
all right all right I can index it huh
have you ever have you ever been have
you ever taken a bath at a hotel yeah
really yeah I actually wanted my bath
nice screw top bottle of wine yeah a
couple of ants you got yourself a bar
yeah get MRSA real nice evening you know
what I mean I uh I remember one time the
real meningitis yeah yeah I remember one
time I was in like a Best Western and
for whatever reason they had this
enormous tub in there and I knew it was
it was like it was it was like in the
living room it was crazy okay uh and I
was like I'm gonna take a nap you gotta
do it you got it here yeah and I and I
and I took like I was there for like
three days and I took like two baths in
it and it was it was a it was wild it
was closer to a pool but I mean many
times I've taken baths in hotels yeah
and I don't feel good about it yeah I
certainly don't the Epsom salt cleave
makes me feel a little better sure but
that's not everybody I've definitely
taken just some raw dog baths in there
yeah you keep your customer receipt from
a credit card like if you pay for dinner
yeah you keep it yep take it with you
yeah you don't just roll it in a bowl
and throw it on the table uh no I take
it I take it with me what are you doing
with it afterwards I don't know my
accountant just I was like remember we
had to save her seats and it was
but if you went into my backpack you'd
be like this is not like they fade they
ink like sure yeah it's not great
um when you were drinking hard liquor
would you order the signature cocktails
at a place no never I had a beer guy
yeah and I and I actually took pleasure
in like drinking the bad whiskey I kind
of do too I like I would like Jim Beam
or I would even order the rail or
whatever well yeah
um have you ever heard that before yeah
well I'm From a Train fan yeah yeah yeah
I've heard that yeah
um have you ever saved a Crown Royal bag
no you got any fireworks at your
apartment right now no but I used to
have a major firework problem in
Wisconsin like lots lots of fireworks I
convinced my English Uncle once when
when I was a 14. I told them we were
gonna go we're gonna light these off in
the house mom
don't burn down anyways
roof yeah yeah I had him take me to go
get fireworks but I convinced them we
were gonna go check out this town called
Racine and lied to him and bought like I
would buy like the [__] borders big
boys yeah yeah his kid's a cowboy God
damn hmm anybody in the family ever
claim to seen a UFO
uh no no no you UFO nope Bigfoot nope
skunk ape no my mother one time said she
saw a winged cat on our porch a winged
cat yeah so there's that wow yeah we
didn't take that one in that's a bird
yeah we've been asking questions
there you go uh let's see growing up to
keep batteries in the refrigerator no
now
ever own a beanbag yes yeah at what age
as a kid I as a kid and then in college
I had a bean bag yeah I think
respectable yeah what kind of furniture
you got in the apartment now you got a
nice sectional chair no okay I well so
my mother moved to LA a couple different
times for a few years okay and lived in
an apartment while you were out there
yeah wow and she had my brother lives
out there too now nice yeah that's a fam
yeah does he have a family out there yep
all right cool yeah so that's pretty
good and um and it's it's good to get
them smoking and um
so my mother is Like My Mother Does have
like good taste and stuff so my mother
bought like some nice furniture okay and
then when she left to go back to England
again I bought that nice furniture off
her so I do have kind of nice furniture
but it's definitely older now but she
didn't just give it to you you had to
buy it all right well I kind of insisted
I was like let me give you like let me
give you 20 bucks yeah she was like I
don't see the point all right then she
didn't really want it the money yeah
yeah she was kind yeah all right good
okay I'll give you that but so the
furniture but but most of the stuff I
would say is is not you know there's
like if you saw me be like a woman
should probably be involved in this
guy's life gotcha that's good though
it's good any sports equipment at the
house right now uh baseball glove
catcher's mitt there's a football
there's a basketball all right all right
does the
um apartment complex have a pool you got
a pool no no pool no okay uh you know
how to tie a tie yep but that's I went
to a school where you had to wear a tie
gotcha how many suits do you own now I
own probably uh five suits but three
from Thailand Ah that's all right though
that's all right like the custom water
like the more like custom fitted ones
yeah but that's you know they fit right
now you go home
there have been some adjustments okay
sure yeah but right now right yeah I
could get in one they called and said
hey you got to beat the Oscars tomorrow
I'd question who's booking it but yeah I
could do it yeah ever been to ever been
in a fight at a sport you were watching
uh no but I've come very close Okay I
when I went and saw the package
they're really scraping the bottom
[Laughter]
Gippy and Hank both swinging alone
it's earned uh I uh I was at the 40
remember the game where Kaepernick made
his highlight reel against the Packers
like I don't know yes it was like he was
like kissing his butt it was like
ridiculous I went to that game almost
fought him I tried to fight him and uh I
went to that game and was real drunk and
was feeling the the fans big [__]
and I started I realized quickly like
shut the [__] up I got into an argument
at a preseason game with a 15 year old
at the Chargers Packers preseason game
probably about 12 years ago Jesus yeah
and that for me was that was not good
were you at that Kaepernick game by
yourself or are you with somebody I was
with a buddy of mine all right cool yeah
have you ever been to a sporting event
by yourself no I don't think I have go
see a movie by yourself yeah take
yourself out to dinner yeah I've done
that yeah okay yeah have you ever tried
to start the wave at a sporting event oh
for sure ever burned a jersey uh never
burned a Jersey no came close with farv
when he went to the Vikings there was
like there was definitely like okay like
I was like I'm getting rid of that
magnet
boy he likes the flame
will you keep the box of something if
you get something will you keep the box
for a while yeah two months yeah yeah
yeah it's usually big on electronics
yeah I'll keep like a TV box unless it's
the floor model okay then I'll be like
how much for the Box uh anyone in your
family Ever represent themselves in
court oh man good one
real good one uh no I don't think so
okay oh that's a I wish oh it's a dream
I'm gonna frame my dad my brother did it
oh it's the biggest
public or drinking in public that's the
best I mean and his logic was how do you
know what was in my cup and I was like
dude that's not gonna work like this
isn't Law and Order permission to
approach the bench I know
uh-huh will you change a table at a
restaurant
no will you send food back no okay no I
will oh yeah I'll just be like whoops
ever just listen to The Sopranos theme
song uh yes I have yes I have yes I have
he got that bumping in the car that was
really good at one point when it was you
know it was just sleep with the lights
on nope what is the sleeping situation
uh what size is the bed the bed is a
queen all right and uh you're single guy
though yep cool yep sleep in the middle
uh I share it with my cat Okay is the
bed in the middle of the room or is it
touching it's multiple walls it's
touching multiple walls yeah it's not
great and uh
and uh no headboard I assume no
headboard all right no nope is there a
bed there's a bed okay well it's a water
bed no there's a bed you have a fitted
sheet I do but again my mother has some
influence over her stuff like this but
yes there's a fitted sheet it's pretty
good but
the bed's a sponsor watermelon
the best of sponsor uh Brooklyn and are
the sheets their spots there you go uh
so you know so that spots I really like
Brooklyn is pricey stuff yeah so but
it's up against the wall yeah no it's
yeah you have a fan in the room yeah
sleep with it on you there's a fan on
the ceiling or is it like a desk fan uh
it's a you know it's an uh there's
possible oscillation if one would if one
would enjoy an oscillation and may I
also point out it has a remote hello
okay thank you gentlemen the batteries
aren't in that thing I'm going to get
them they're in the freezer
good Lord that definitely has a cord
running through the bedroom it's uh
definitely got probably connected to an
extension cord probably an outdoors
outdoor extension
guy yeah the big yellow guy with the
black head you go to sleep watching TV
yep they eat watching TV where do you
normally eat your meals if you cook at
home I'll just see on the couch on the
couch watching watching TV yeah okay you
got a Swiffer nope who cleans the
apartment I do I'm pretty clean you do
yeah I gotta mop I I'll go pretty big
okay I'm pretty good about that ain't
bad mop though yikes like a string mop
yeah really like janitary much Jesus
yeah yeah yeah I even put up the little
yellow conscience it's a wet floor watch
out Gareth make sure the cat doesn't sue
me yeah yeah uh you take your shoes off
in the house yeah well if a guests come
over well they have to take their shoes
off yeah that'd be a request and then
yeah if we came over to the house right
now you'd say hey can you guys take your
shoes off uh or we would ask we would
ask then I'd be like yeah yeah and what
would you offer us to drink what do you
have in the house water wise or uh
probably a liquid death water okay uh
warmer in the fridge fridge all right
and then outside of that uh it wouldn't
be much
you like wine yeah yeah you can take
this top off these little Sutter homes
do you cook at home a lot would you say
yeah you do yeah where are you shopping
out there in la la land uh I mean mainly
I mean it varies I'll go to lassens
which is a more uh uh I think it's
Mormon Run Grocery Store really yeah but
they just have good produce I go to the
farmer's market a lot nothing on that
yeah what did you say I said you can
have as many bags as you want
hey we don't discriminate over here yeah
I do a lot of farm
help them dude he probably steals from
him yeah yeah
and these dumb yokels can't count them
down the street shirt full of radishes
free dirt the produce sucks but I love
the haggling yeah that's pretty good you
do a lot of yeah
that's not bad
I mean you're gonna need a lot to get
you out of where you currently yeah you
have a full set of silverware yeah okay
are they in silverware dividers yep
really yep all right do you own a set of
kitchen tongs
I don't think I have tongs but I have a
lot of stuff you have a pizza cutter I
have a pizza cutter what's the Mayo
situation when you were a kid and now
not in the mail loved it as a kid loved
it as a kid do you remember what your
mom would get uh I think Miracle Whip
she's British you got to cut her some
slack yeah
Foley now hates you by the way the fact
that I saw a demerit put on the paper is
really tough isn't the ACT is all over
again
yeah uh huh HP Sauce sorry Kippy oh
please uh yeah yeah HP had it had
probably in the house as a kid yo yeah
got a bottle in your fridge now I have a
bottle of it yes what else you got in
that fridge on that on that on the door
there'll be ketchup there'll be a lot of
what kind of brand we talking about
ketchup and mustard uh ketchup I feel
like will be like one of those like all
natural gotcha ones from lessons uh
mustard I think same thing I like like
you know like Dijon mustard but I'm sure
if like a regular like smart person
would come over they'd be like that's
not good but I like it with the little
mustard seeds in it so something like
that grain mustard yeah
um there would be some ranch dressing
Hidden Valley no probably again like a
like more rain a little more company
okay
um so you're eating pretty good yeah I
do
you're going a little organic you're
doing the farmer's market where are you
getting your Meats from I don't eat meat
you don't eat so I'm a vegetarian I eat
eggs but no meat yeah how long have you
been a vegetarian uh probably about 10
years now 10 years vegetarian yeah so
there's no meat so don't get meat I get
like fake meat but I don't even eat that
a lot okay I ate a lot of like I eat a
lot of veg so what would a meal be
uh Beef Wellington no I mean a meal
would be like rare as hell yeah I would
say like I mean potatoes and rice and
beans and things like that like all
mixed up versions yeah but that's what I
cook a lot at home and it's not really
that varied you know like my diet when
I'm at home is pretty normal and then
when I go on the road like I put on like
10 pounds of Road weight because you
said you like ribs I used to so you
haven't had ribs in 10 years no any you
[__] mess with any fast food not
really no because it's like yeah it's
kind of like yeah it kind of filters
itself out yeah when you would visit
your mom was there any British food that
you were really stoked on like fish and
chips used to I used to put on like 15
pounds of fish and chip weight I love it
you know have a Cod gut like I really
loved fish and chips Greg sausage roll
or like an area sausage roll great yeah
love those it's like such a simple diet
there but I love fish and chips was like
the greatest thing what's your go-to
British candy
I would say probably maltesers maltesers
yeah they're kind of like Whoppers okay
yeah they call them something don't they
call them milk something over there too
isn't there a brand milk something oh
yeah there's uh what is it purple
wrapper yeah yeah is it dairy milk dairy
milk yeah I think it's dairy milk what
about those pigs ears that everyone eats
over there you know I'm talking about
pigs they're like for dogs they're gummy
bears but they're uh piggy ears or
something like that I don't know little
pink piggies or something I thought they
were a popular British guy I don't know
I know your Mars Bars don't have any
peanuts in them yeah almonds and
Snickers used to be called Marathon for
some reason crazy yeah that was not okay
that was a hate crime I work I mean I
think I got all I need to render a
judgment here well I shouldn't have
represented myself oh yeah there you go
dumb idea you did Rip Your represent
yourself in the in the court of garbage
yeah
this might pull them out black olives or
green olives black
canned pitted Let's Dance come on
what kind of frozen pizza will you mess
with there you go uh I would say
probably DiGiorno yeah it's my favorite
but it's trashy yeah oh yeah but I mean
I loved it growing up you eat cheese
right yep you do cheese and I'll eat in
a hotel I'll even get the hotel Pizza
where you gotta fold the silver top on
and I'll eat that and be like that's
pretty good I gotta like the out of the
lobby the lobby Pizza I don't use the
microwave if you have it in the hotel
room yes use the business center
no
I love I do love the business center
though when there's a guy saddest deal
being closed ever a computer
man none of that [__] ever worked will
you use the coffee maker no I'll use the
coffee maker whoa this is the coffee
maker this morning wow holy [__] I don't
feel good yeah dude it's because you're
drinking pissed yeah I paint them I'm
fine I peed them too it's the circle
what's the wallet situation uh it's like
a uh it's a bridge wallet it's velcro
for sure it's all in the sock
yeah yeah keep your eyes on stuff in the
standings it's all in this song Nobody
Can Oliver it out of your sack uh it's a
money clip that a fan gave me a Packers
money clip that's very sweet you're
still trash yeah I don't know what to
tell you brother yeah no it's not I mean
no I feel like a wild world of Gareth
isn't that great [__] home run Gareth
Reynolds everybody what a [__] treat
look at you yeah no it's not easy to get
here it's easy to look at you no I know
it's not been an easy Road
yeah it wasn't easy to get it from the
depths of Hell Jesus yeah no no here we
are real far from Buckingham Palace
in front of you
oh man gang Gareth Reynolds we love you
to death that was [__] fantastic wow
thank you so much for having me congrats
on the special yeah congratulations
thank you very much England weed and the
rest yeah all things comedy over there
on the YouTube yeah you can just go to
my website garethrenals.com and there's
a little thing there you can click the
special I love it you got a tour coming
up anything you want the folks out there
to know hit them plug away uh listen to
the dollop uh you can go to
garethrones.com for tour dates I'll be
all over the Midwest and I'll be back on
the east coast and I'm always on the
road great man we love it Kippy what do
you got for him uh our new tours
announced we're coming all over the
place March April man get those tickets
now before those shows sell out we love
you first stop Maryland gang we love you
to death Gareth thank you so much
pleasure we'll see you next week